i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
my name is brittany broski but most
people know me as kombucha girl
this all started in august of 2019. i
was 22 years old i was living in dallas
texas
i worked at a bank in trusted investment
services
life was very normal for me i had no
idea
what was coming i downloaded tech talk
as a joke
because i kept seeing ads for it on
snapchat
and i was like what is this people in
furry suits and all this like cosplay
was kind of like
the main thing on the app and then just
by accident i started uploading because
i ended up having a lot of fun on the
app
i didn't even know what kombucha was and
uh i just kind of wanted to try it i was
at the grocery store one time
and i walked by the aisle and i was like
why not so i bought it
i just kind of got home put all my
groceries away set up my camera
and just filmed me trying it
no well and
the reaction is genuine i mean it's kind
of nasty but the flavor i got was like a
soda so it was kind of sugary
and it didn't do well on tick-tock it
was
downloaded and uploaded to gay twitter
and they took that and captioned it
when i ate for the first time and other
ones like when i tasted
for the first time and all these nasty
like i work at
a bank and i dm the guy who first
uploaded the video and i was like hey
like this is me in hopes that he would
take it down because i was like i don't
want to get fired but he was like oh
this is you
and tagged me under it and i was like oh
[ __ ]
so then i started getting an influx of
followers i had a private account with
maybe like
400 followers it was me and my friends
in a day
i got like 12 000 requests and i was
like well man i guess it's time to go
public so i made my account public i
gained 96
000 twitter followers in one day like it
is insane how fast
it spread the meme actually like not the
video but the two reaction pictures
it there's no language affiliated with
it so it that's how it went so viral is
it doesn't take
an english speaker to think faces are
funny i started seeing my face on like
hong kong protest posters climate change
posters in new zealand like it was
global insane you know then it's like
well how do i tell my boss what's going
on when you're 50
60 like having to explain the idea of a
meme
like as jinzy to a boomer is like
i would rather die so i had to explain
to her this wasn't me
like i didn't caption it when i ate for
the first time
it's someone that's taken my video and
captioned it with a funny caption
so whatever you see like it's out of my
control so
there was a fateful day early september
where i was pulled into my boss's office
and she was basically like
you need to choose if you want to be a
meme or if you want to be
a corporate professional i don't know
girl i have rent to pay obviously i want
to be a professional like what do you
want me to do go work at outback
steakhouse
so i was like no please like it's just a
hobby and she was like okay
but then sure enough i mean a week later
like she brought me in slid a piece of
paper across the table and was like you
know
i think we're gonna let you go i was
mortified i was so embarrassed to tell
my dad
of like i got fired from a bank job like
that's so embarrassing for what
because i'm posting videos of me doing
online like i graduated college i
graduated in three years i was magna [ __ ]
laude like i work i'm a licensed
insurance agent i worked at a bank like
i have every intention of being
a functioning member of society i
understand and i don't hold it against
them at all like having a young
20-something-year-old
fresh college grad [ __ ] around online
saying i'm a banker
like all it takes is one google search
so i made sure
when i had that call with my parents
that i you know like there is a backup
plan it's not just me
sitting on my unemployed i had a team
behind me at that point
and you know a week later i was flown
out to la i was
meeting with the platform headquarters i
started working with comedy central
mtv like all these major brands and
networks
i was a presenter at the streamies i was
in a super bowl commercial
i was nominated for a shortie award tick
tocker of the year like what i
i literally can't even keep up and
that's not even the brands that i've
worked with it's
just a dream you know it wasn't just hey
can you recreate the meme like i was
pumping out
other content i was doing accents
impressions
skits like what i've always done and now
that all the eyes are on me i was like
if there was ever a time to create
content it's now
caleb caleb mom says get out of the tub
quit trying to drown yourself then it's
ready
literally we're almost coming up on to
the day it's august
something right now and i just hit 5.1
million
being a meme is very dehumanizing
people forget you're a real person like
if someone would tag me in something i'd
respond they'd be like
oh my god it's like yeah i'm real i had
some old like tinder
matches text me again and i was like why
no no absolutely not
block i have every intention of you know
stand up snl audition all that my number
one is voice acting i want to be in a
pixar film so bad i want a voice act for
a disney film
it's like i'm a multifaceted person i
have so much more to offer than just
you know what i mean but it was such a
learning experience
and it's got me where i am and i'm very
grateful to be where i am
so hey disney pixar hey blue sky studios
how y'all doing
call me
[Music]
you